cara is in providence rhode island hi
kara how are you
hi dave and anthony i'm doing well how
are you better than i deserve how can we
help
so two asides first aside is
we have made literally every financial
mistake you have ever told
anyone not to do and
me too and the second aside is
over the last few years i have checked
your book out of the
library probably at least 10 times
um 2020 came i started going back to
church
i checked your book out of the library
at the end of the year and you know what
i
we got through baby step one we're on
baby step two but here it is
we are two working parents um
work out of the house i work monday
through friday you know nine to five my
husband works
as many saturdays but monday through
friday and as many saturdays
and we've got two little kids they are
in
daycare and we have
aside from our not including our actual
mortgage
we have 140 000 worth of debt and
i am tracking every penny um i
have adjusted our grocery budget
unfortunately our kids have to be in a
sub-par daycare situation
uh because we just can't afford for them
to be in a
you know a better situation what's your
household income
um i bring in about 40 and he brings in
about 60 sometimes a little more he
works in construction i work in
ironically banking um
and what is the nature of the 140 000
worth of debt oh like i said it's
everything it's student loans
it's uh consolidated credit cards
it's a fleece that was turned into a car
loan because
i did the math out and we just didn't
have any other way to go at that point
in time
you know if it's the pmi
for our home if it's just a
conglomeration of all of the stuff
you're not supposed to do
your pmi is in the 140.
yeah cause that's it's it's well it's
eight it's you know it was uh
no excuse the answer it was the first
the twenty percent down so
i don't consider that our mortgage our
mortgage is 233 and that
uh first that one per uh the 20
down wasn't is part of an fha loan we
could borrow both
nothing down so that 8 000 is in that
does that make sense yeah yeah so how
much do you own your car because
otherwise
um i owe 19 even though it's worth 12
and then his truck is 4 thousand
so we're doing the bet snowball where i
i mean we're stacking
everything we can um i used all of our
tax return all of the stimulus money
went to
debt so that was a nice you know five
thousand dollars we could throw but
basically we're probably looking at like
i don't know seven to ten years left
of at least just getting this stuff down
and i'm just wondering like this is
gonna be a long game i know it is but
i'm and we're dedicated to it we're
doing what we can i just you know
words of advice anything you might
suggest i
my dad said that he had an idea of
as far as like the leaf where the 19
owed on the 12 worth he said
i could probably get like a a
a loan for a smaller rate pay that off
and then
because i need a vehicle we both work
and
i i pick up our kids and bring them to
daycare like we both need vehicles
um he said you know maybe
get something a loan at a lower rate pay
off the the vehicle
sell it and get something cheaper i'm
just
there's so many things that i'm trying
to do and we're literally i'm throwing
every like extra five bucks i can
at our debt and we're we're going but
it's
i just you know i responded by so much
um we have been together for six years
we've been
officially married for a year um we
couldn't afford to even have like a nice
wedding
but you know what so you've been dying
you've been doing stop
stop stop stop okay i've done a lot of
stupid stuff with my money you said you
said you opened the conversation said
you've done every dumb thing right
and so you've done six years worth of
mistakes
you've been working on you've been
working on turning this ship around
for a month and a half two months
until up until this up until this
calendar year you didn't really work on
it
you read out the book but you weren't
really doing anything
you've gotten serious in the last 30 to
60 days
yeah now i'm feeling just completely
overwhelmed yeah it's not going to take
as long as you think it's going to take
okay you just it takes a little while to
get started number one
and then number two you're going to get
some momentum
uh but it's six years worth of mistakes
they're not going to go away in six
months
no i know that i know but it's not 10
years either it's 140 000
that's fourteen thousand dollars a year
that you're going to pay off in debt
making a hundred thousand that's absurd
of course you're not going to do that
and so 30 30 000 a year in debt
reduction
would get you out in five years and
you're going to do more than that
but you just haven't found it all yet
and you because you're just
getting started and uh you're just
you know but but i don't know what math
you're running but you're not going to
pay off 14 000
you're making 100 000. you're going to
do a lot more than that
well my concern is our mortgage is
16 40. a day care is anywhere from 14 to
1800 dollars a month
plus all of our other debts so it's just
like i said i'm literally
i i run your mortgage is 18 000 yeah
a year out of a hundred thousand how big
how big a tax refund is
how big a tax refund did you get um i
got i got about uh
i think it was just under three thousand
we
yeah yeah i'm sorry okay so that's two
that's 250
a month that's 250 a month too much
coming out of your check
have you adjusted your w-2s yet
i i don't think no i i he has not yet no
i i know he hasn't okay somebody needs
somebody needs to adjust your w-2
yeah but both of you together or
whatever by about 250
a month that's going to help a little
getting rid of your car is going to help
a little
and somebody's getting you into a
hooptie and somebody's going to extra
job dave yeah and he's going to be
working
he works construction that's good news
he knows how to fix stuff and so he's
going to be fixing stuff a bunch on the
weekends yeah
yeah all the time you guys are gonna be
working 80 hours a week absolutely
it's time it's time you guys have been a
slave
to this stuff long enough you're gonna
have to rise up and bust it in the nose
and you're you've just begun i i know
you can do it
i've seen people exactly where you are
to do this yes many many
thousands of times over the decades i've
been doing this
but what i do know is is that the your
your sense of being overwhelmed your
sense of being stuck that your sense of
this is going to take forever comes from
the fact that the math does not lay out
perfectly in front of you right now to
where you can see everything easily
and if you're not careful you're going
to say well it's not i just can't do
this
yeah and you're going to walk away you
can do this but you're going to have to
continue to fight
scratch claw do anything you can do to
get your income up and you're out go
down
and you're going to sell stuff sell so
much stuff the kids think they're next
there's a whole
bunch of stuff that you've got to do a
whole bunch of moves you've got to make
and stop coming up with excuses start
coming up with solutions
sit down with your husband say all right
babe we have five years to make this
happen
what do we need to do to make that
happen within the next five years yeah
we're gonna help you i'm going to put
you through ramsey plus i'll put you
through financial peace university put
you in the premium version of every
dollar
i'm going to pay for it for a year you
and your husband get in front of those
videos
get in those communities talk to those
coaches
those folks our team will walk with you
we will show you how to do this you can
do this
but it's gonna be very hard it's gonna
be worth it
this is the ramsey show